So that was a bit of a whistle-stop tour on the kind of fundamental building blocks of getting gameplay working
But one thing we also really need to touch on is garbage collection as already mentioned unreal is a garbage collected
Engine it's built on top of C++, which obviously isn't garbage collected, but that functionality has been implemented over the top
as mentioned earlier the
Most of the unreal garbage collection system is managed through the reflection macros
So when if we want something garbage collected it essentially needs to be marked up either as a uclass, a ustruct or a uproperty
The way garbage collection actually works is that unreal keeps a root set of u objects
That acts as the base for the garbage collected kind of iterative searches
And we'll touch on the root set in just a second to go into any more detail about how that works
Actors can be explicitly destroyed and that's how we easily remove things from that root set and once an actor has been destroyed
It'll get cleaned up by the garbage collector at the next garbage collection. This also means that any
properties or any
components on that actor
That aren't already being referenced by other things will get cleaned up
And actors own components will get automatically garbage collected at that point, too
So just going into a little bit about how the root set actually works like we said
Unreal maintains a kind of core root set of objects. You can add objects to this root set yourself if you need to
But if we were to kind of step through a garbage collection flow
The way unreal begins is it assumes that every object outside of that root set is unreachable
So it marks everything as needing garbage collection
It then goes through a series of iterative searches to try and build up connections where it can
To see what is and is not reachable
So in this example here
We have an object which references down a chain and we can see now all of these objects are reachable and therefore
None of them would get garbage collected if at the end of this iterative search any of these objects
Didn't have other objects referencing them. Then that would be marked up for garbage collection and cleaned up
If at some point we were to break one of these connections
So say for example objects one here was our level of level world and we've destroyed an actor
So object three is an actor
we've destroyed it that would be breaking its connection with the world and therefore the root set and
Therefore both the actor and the actors component would get garbage collected
so it's not just
The reflected types that can get garbage collected. It's not just a U class or a U struct
We can do it in another way if we have non U objects that we need to
Have still handle garbage collection
We can inherit from the FGC object class and that just implements this function of add referenced objects
And that way you can add in references to U objects and any type that inherits from that to a non U object class
You just need to make sure that you implement those functions and within that function you reference each one of the objects that you need
to be
Seen by the garbage collector
When working with garbage collection, there's a couple of key things to bear in mind
So whenever we're talking about U objects that manipulation isn't thread safe
It's highly highly recommended that we only manipulate and access
U objects on the game thread
It is possible to do it on other threads
But we need to use proper use of synchronization techniques and primitives to make sure that we don't get parallel programming errors
So be cautious because that can lead to performance
hitches
The garbage collector can't see raw pointers inside U objects. So even though the reflection
The unreal reflection system looks inside U classes and U structs if you have raw pointers
They're just not going to be seen by garbage collection
So you either need a U object for U property markup, or you can also use the shared pointer library
Which we'll get on to in a moment
Last of all, we can mark objects for pending kill
Which is essentially our manual way of marking sending an object for garbage collection. Actors can be destroyed
That's kind of a distinct thing
But generally we can mark an object up for pending kill the pending being the key word there because when you do that
It's not instantly
Deleted from the root set that simply breaks that connection and the next time garbage collection actually gets run
That's when the objects will be removed from memory
So it's only at the point of garbage collection pending kill simply says this will get garbage collected the next time we run garbage collection